[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Mittagsgericht.
Ich sage es noch mal.
Wir haben gedacht, wir machen mal
was leckeres Vegetarisches:
Gemüseauflauf aus dem Ofen.
Und ich nehme jetzt einfach Gemüse der Saison,
mache eine leckere Soße dazu.
Das Ganze geht ziemlich schnell
und ist auch ganz einfach.
Ich verwende
oder ich bereite jetzt zuerst einmal die Soße zu
und verwende dafür
20 Gramm Butter,
20 Gramm Mehl,
400 Gramm Milch,
eine Knoblauchzehe,
ein bisschen Muskatnuss,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Zum Würzen nehme ich noch den Tulum-Käse,
also den Nomadenkäse,
eine Stange Porree,
etwas Rosmarin.
Und als Gemüse habe ich jetzt hier
einen Kürbis,
Rote Bete,
Petersilienwurzel,
Kartoffeln
und zum Überbacken Kaşar-Käse.
Wenn ihr das Ganze würziger machen wollt,
weil ihr zum Beispiel Blauschimmelkäsefan seid,
könnt ihr statt Tulum-Käse auch Blauschimmelkäse machen
und
– oder Gorgonzola.
Ich glaube, das ist ja so ein Blauschimmelkäse.
Zum Überbacken könnt ihr den Kaşar nehmen
oder einen Gouda oder einen Mozzarella.
Also da seid ihr ganz frei.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach die Zutaten, die ich heute hier habe,
und starte auch direkt mit der Soße, würde ich sagen.
Ich nehme jetzt hierfür einfach diesen Bräter.
Denn der passt
– das ist so der kleine, eckige Bräter aus Gusseisen.
Der passt nämlich in den Ofen.
Und vor allem kann ich den hier auf dem Herd benutzen
und dann im Ofen benutzen
und spare mir einfach einen Topf.
Und da mache ich jetzt erst mal eine Mehlschwitze.
[Musik]
Was ich hier schon mal machen kann, ist
die Knoblauchzehe fein hacken.
[Musik]
Dann gebe ich die Knoblauchzehe nämlich direkt mit dazu.
Dann kann die schön mit anbraten.
Das gibt dann echt einen feinen Geschmack.
Dann direkt das Mehl mit anbraten.
So bindet die Soße gleich auch.
Und jetzt einfach so ein bisschen bräunen.
Und ihr könnt jetzt auch hier beim Gemüse natürlich variieren
und sagen
– wenn ihr jetzt kein Kürbisfan seid,
so wie Murat zum Beispiel,
nehmt ihr Karotten oder Blumenkohl oder Brokkoli.
Alles, was ihr so dahabt, könnt ihr jetzt verwerten
und alles, was ihr gerne habt.
Ich bin zum Beispiel auch ein großer Fan von
– wie heißen die kleinen? –
Rosenkohl.
Aber dem Murat muss ich immer
das Gemüse so ein bisschen unterjubeln.
Der wird mich auch später fragen: "Wo ist das Fleisch?"
Aber es gibt halt kein Fleisch.
Oh, ich wollte doch getrocknete Tomaten reinmachen.
Mh!
Ich glaube, die mache ich noch mit rein.
Weil, ich finde, die haben
so einen richtig schönen Biss dann immer.
Das darf jetzt hier gerne so vor sich hin köcheln.
Und ich kann schon mal
die Porreestange zerkleinern.
Ich habe die jetzt von außen gewaschen.
Ich werde sie jetzt schneiden
und dann innen noch mal waschen,
weil einfach Porree oftmals voll ist mit Sand.
Die äußeren Blätter hier so ein bisschen wegnehmen.
[Musik]
Und ich nehme jetzt hier einfach die Salatschleuder,
kann hier den Porree reingeben
und dann mit Wasser auffüllen
und einmal richtig gut durchschleudern,
dass einfach der ganze Sand weggeschwemmt wird.
Und immer schön auf die Soße aufpassen.
[Musik]
Und dann ruhig trocken schleudern.
Dann geht so noch mal der ganze Rest raus.
Okay.
Den Porree gebe ich jetzt hier auch direkt dazu.
Der soll nämlich mit in die Soße.
Und dann die Soße mit Muskat abschmecken
und mit Pfeffer.
Salz gebe ich jetzt mal noch nicht dazu.
Denn der Käse kommt ja gleich noch mit rein.
Und ich will es jetzt einfach nicht überwürzen.
Noch mal ein bisschen hochstellen.
Dann kann das hier so ein bisschen durchziehen.
Ich lege jetzt hier noch den Rosmarin dazu.
Und wie gesagt, lasse ich das jetzt kurz durchziehen.
Der Käse bleibt auch mal hier.
Und ich kümmere mich schon mal ums Gemüse.
Ich nehme jetzt, wie gesagt, ein bisschen Kürbis auch
und nehme jetzt hier den Hokkaido,
weil ich den nicht schälen muss,
aber entkernen.
Und den schneide ich jetzt so in Scheiben.
[Musik]
Mh, Rot mache ich zum Schluss,
damit die Hände verschont bleiben.
Die Petersilienwurzel einfach auch schälen.
Und ich mache jetzt eher eine kleinere Portion,
so für zwei, drei Personen
oder für Josh und mich,
und schneide wirklich alles einfach schön in Scheiben.
Und ich orientiere mich jetzt auch so ein bisschen,
muss ich sagen, an den Farben
und werde das auch gleich farblich so ein bisschen sortieren.
Denn ich glaube
– also ich finde, das Auge isst da schon mit
und es sollte schon schön ansprechend sein.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch das ganze Gemüse
einfach durchmischen
und euch gar nicht die Arbeit machen.
Aber, wenn ihr das gleich so anordnet,
dann kann man sich natürlich auch das Gemüse aussuchen.
Und so jemand wie der Murat,
der eben absolut keinen Kürbis mag,
kann dann eben den Kürbis einfach weglassen.
Oder ihr mischt es durch, damit er es probieren muss.
Wäre natürlich auch eine Alternative.
Man kann ja auch so einen Regenbogen machen.
Sieht ja auch schön aus für Kids.
[Musik]
So.
Und zu guter Letzt die Rote Bete.
Und, weil ich keine roten Hände haben will,
nehme ich da jetzt Handschuhe.
Denn frische Rote Bete, die färbt echt enorm gut.
Also, wenn ihr da auch nicht wollt,
dass euer Schneidebrett sich verfärbt,
auf jeden Fall aufpassen.
[Musik]
Okay. Dann geht es jetzt direkt schon ans Schichten.
Und ich gebe jetzt hier noch,
wie gesagt, zum Würzen den Käse dazu.
Und das ist einfach wie so eine Art Hirtenkäse,
so im Fass gereift, der Nomadenkäse,
richtig lecker würzig, aber nicht zu käsig.
Also ich als nicht so doller Käseliebhaber
– ich mag ja nicht so riechende, stinkende Käsesorten.
Aber der ist echt gut.
Der bringt so eine Würze mit rein.
[Musik]
Das Gemüse kann ich jetzt schon mal ein bisschen vorwürzen
mit Salz und Pfeffer,
dass es auch schon mal
so einen eigenen Geschmack bekommt.
Und jetzt richte ich das Ganze
so an.
Ich meine, ihr könnt es jetzt, wie gesagt,
durcheinander reinlegen, aber ich will
einfach so eine farbliche Sortierung.
[Musik]
Ja, ich werde jetzt einen Deckel draufgeben.
Es ist gerade ein bisschen schade,
dass ich keine zweite Pfanne habe.
Denn ich könnte jetzt einfach die zweite Pfanne,
schwups, obendrauf legen
und hätte einen geschlossenen Bräter.
Aber ich mache es einfach anders.
Ihr könnt jetzt entweder Folie nehmen, Alufolie
oder
einen
– geht doch, oder? –
einen anderen passenden Deckel.
So kommt das jetzt bei mir
für eine halbe Stunde in den Backofen,
kann schön durchziehen.
So hat man nämlich den Vorteil,
dass eben die Flüssigkeit aus dem Gemüse
in der ganzen Soße drin auch bleibt
und das Ganze eben sozusagen dampfgart.
Wenn ihr es offen macht,
dann trocknet das Gemüse und gart zwar auch,
aber eben nicht im eigenen Saft.
Deswegen mache ich das jetzt so in den Ofen.
Ja. Und dann decken wir es wieder auf
und dann kommt der Käse drüber.
Und aus dem Rest mache ich jetzt
noch eine kleine vegane Portion
mit veganer Butter und veganer Milch
für unsere Veganer.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr jetzt noch
gerne getrocknete Tomaten dazu geben.
Ich nehme jetzt die, die ich selber eingelegt habe,
die Cocktailtomaten.
Die sind, muss ich auch echt sagen
– weil ja der Murat immer sagt so:
"Oh, Fleischersatz, Fleischersatz."
Ich finde, so getrocknete Tomaten
auch von der Konsistenz her
sind echt wie so ein Fleischersatz,
weil die zum einen megawürzig sind
und auch diese Konsistenz halt haben.
Und dann noch etwas Käse drüber
und noch mal in den Backofen zum Gratinieren.
Und dann ist das Gericht fertig.
Und ich finde, das ist echt was megaleckeres Schnelles,
leicht auch eigentlich,
recht leicht wegen dem vielen Gemüse,
sättigend trotzdem
und vor allem ganz einfach,
weil ich echt nur eine Schüssel
oder eine Ofenform schmutzig gemacht habe,
obwohl ich am Herd war.
So. Ich mache jetzt mal nicht so viel Käse,
weil ich mag es nicht so, wenn es zu voll mit Käse ist.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Das ist mein Himmel auf Erden.
>> SALLY: Du bist mein Himmel auf Erden.
>> SARAH: Oh!
Süß!
>> JOSH: Das ist die Hölle auf Erden.
>> SARAH: Wir sind so die Ingwertee trinkende,
Porridge essende Gemüsefraktion.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: So wir zwei, wir essen immer
– immer, wenn es heißt: "Was wollt ihr essen?",
>> SALLY: Gemüse.
>> SARAH: "Irgendwas mit Gemüse wäre schön."
>> SALLY: Wir haben heute Morgen
schon so Sellerie gesnackt und Havuç.
>> SARAH: Havuç!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt – mein Gott! Also...
>> SARAH: Die Betonung liegt auf dem U.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Havuç!
>> SALLY: Ja, bei dir schon, nicht?
Also...
>> SARAH: Bei allen Menschen auf der Welt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Sarah bringt uns Türkisch bei.
Mmh!
>> SARAH: Oh! Was probiere ich als Erstes?
>> SALLY: Voll gut!
>> SALLY: Mit dem Lauch unten.
>> SARAH: Rote Bete!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Soll ich was über Rote Bete erzählen?
>> SALLY: Erzähl.
Komm, hau es raus.
>> SARAH: Der Flo hat mir damals immer,
als wir uns kennengelernt haben,
immer Rote-Bete-Salat gemacht
mit Parmesan und Walnüssen.
Das hat er morgens frisch zubereitet,
weil er wusste, dass ich das so mag.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Der Murat hat nur einmal für mich gekocht.
>> SARAH: Echt? Was war das?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Das hast du im Podcast erzählt.
>> SALLY: Ja, Lachs-Tagliatelle
>> SARAH: Oh! Ich habe es angehört.
>> SALLY: und so Thunfischbrötchen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann nie wieder.
Weil dann hat er mein Herz erobert.
>> SARAH: Toll. So schnell geht das?
>> JOSH: Aber war das nicht sogar für Freunde?
>> SALLY: Für mich und meine Freunde.
Denn, wie der Murat sagt,
du musst nicht die Frau erobern, sondern ihre Freunde.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Der Flo musste mir mindestens sechs bis sieben Mal
Rote-Bete-Salat zubereiten.
>> SALLY: Na toll.
>> SARAH: Er hat mir sogar
– als ich Berufsschule hatte,
hat er mir damals für die Schule
meinen Rote-Bete-Salat gerichtet.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich war einfach zu gutmütig direkt,
gutgläubig.
Oh! Aber wie lecker ist das bitte?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Und das wäre jetzt so eine Portion...
>> SARAH: Oh, der Kürbis!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Der Kürbis ist mega.
Das wäre jetzt so eine Portion,
ich glaube, die würde für uns...
Also wir würden viermal davon essen, nicht?
Also jeder...
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also so vier Portionen sind es für uns
oder zwei Sally- und Sarah-Portionen
und eine Josh-Portion.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> SARAH: Der Josh isst immer mehr als wir.
Aber er braucht es ja auch.
>> SALLY: Ja, er ist ja auch größer und stärker.
>> SARAH: Stärker nicht,
größer.
>> JOSH: Das...
>> SARAH: Wir machen mal eine Übung.
>> SALLY: Okay. Das Rezept gibt es auf
sallys-blog.de
oder in meiner App.
Probiert es gerne aus.
Und ihr könnt, wie gesagt, das Gemüse auch austauschen.
Ding ist ja auch voll lecker, Rosenkohl.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und überhaupt Kohl im Allgemeinen.
>> SARAH: Lauch ist auch drin, gell?
>> SALLY: Lauch ist unten drin.
>> SARAH: Mega!
>> SALLY: Lauch ist so die Basis
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: und obendrauf dann so das geschichtete Gemüse.
>> SARAH: Also am besten schmeckt mir Kürbis
>> SALLY: Mir auch.
>> SARAH: und Rote Bete.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Und das hat auch die schönsten Farben.
>> SALLY: Finde ich auch.
>> SARAH: Das ist gut.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde, die Kartoffeln hätten für mich
nicht mal sein müssen.
So zum Sattwerden brauche ich nicht unbedingt Kartoffeln.
>> SARAH: Gehen dann auch Süßkartoffeln?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Die wären auch lecker, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja, klar.
Also so mein Papa und der Murat, die sind so
– die brauchen so richtig handfeste Kohlenhydrate,
weißt, so zum Sattwerden.
Nudeln, Brot, Kartoffeln.
>> SARAH: Wir gar nicht, gell?
>> SALLY: Wir gar nicht.
>> SARAH: Ich werde auch von einer Havuç satt.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich auch.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
Und schreibt gerne mal,
welche Gemüsegerichte ihr als Nächstes sehen wollt
oder ob ihr mehr so der Gemüsefan seid
oder doch der Fleischesser.
[Musik]
Machen wir so ein Standbild zum Schluss?
Einfach nicht mehr bewegen.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay, reicht.
[Musik]